now when it comes to following the  governor's mask mandate Northern Nevada  is doing a better job than Southern  Nevada a report from OSHA found that 66  percent of businesses in Southern Nevada  and 84 percent in Northern Nevada were  in compliance surveys on July 3rd  included places like water parks who  were found not enforcing the mandate in  fact 40% of resort pools and 80% of bars  and 80 percent of casino floors just  last week Caesars Entertainment sent a  memo to all employees alerting them that  not wearing a mask is grounds for  termination all right so this brings us  now to our 8 News Now poll we asked do  you think those working on casino floors  should be fired if they refuse to wear a  mask well here's the number so that the  early point of the night 66 percent say  yes they do feel they should be fired 34  percent say no